welcome everyone this is the first
screencast in our series on in context
learning this series is a kind of
companion to the one that we did on
information retrieval the two series
come together to help you with homework
2 and bake off two which is focused on
few shot open domain question answering
with frozen retrievers and Frozen large
language models
to start this series I thought we would
just reflect a bit on the origins of the
idea of in context learning which is
really a story of how NLP got to this
strange and exciting and chaotic moment
for the field and maybe also for the
society more broadly
all credit to the Chomsky bot for
bringing us to this moment
I'm only joking the the Chomsky bot is a
very simple
pattern-based language model it's been
around since the 90s I believe and with
very simple mechanisms it produces Pros
that is roughly in the style of the
political philosopher and sometimes
linguist Noam Chomsky it produces prose
that Delights and maybe informs us and
the underlying mechanisms are very
simple and I think that's a nice
reminder about what all of these large
language models might be doing even in
the present day
but I'm only joking although it's only
partly a joke I think when we think
about precedence for in context learning
it is worth mentioning that in the
pre-deep learning era engram based
language models very sparse large
language models were often truly massive
for example brands at all 2007 use a 300
billion parameter language model trained
on 2 trillion tokens of text to help
with machine translation that is a very
large and very powerful mechanism with a
different character from the large
language models of today but it is
nonetheless worth noting that they
played an important role in a lot of
different fields way back when
I think for in context learning as we
know it now the earliest paper as far as
I know is the DECA NLP paper this is
McCann adult 2018. they do multitask
training with task instructions that are
natural language questions and that does
seem that like the origin of the idea
that with freeform natural language
instructions we could essentially end up
with artifacts that could do multiple
things guided solely by text
and then it's worth noting also that in
the GPT paper Radford at all 2018 you
can find buried in there some tentative
proposals to do prompt-based uh
experiments with that model
but the real origins of the ideas again
as far as I know are Radford at all 2019
this is the gpt2 paper
and let me just show you some Snippets
from this paper it's really inspiring
how much they did they say at the start
we demonstrate language models can
perform Downstream tasks in a zero shot
setting without any parameter or
architecture modification so there you
see this idea of using Frozen models
prompting them and seeing if they will
produce interesting behaviors
they looked at a bunch of different
tasks for summarization they say to
induce summarization Behavior we add the
text tldr after the article and generate
100 tokens this is mind-blowing I
remember when I first heard about this
idea I had such a cognitive bias against
in context learning of this sort being
successful that I assumed what they were
trying to say to us is that they had
trained that token
uh in a task specific way to do
summarization and then just kind of
given it a colorful name but no they
really meant it they simply prompt the
model with this token and look at what
comes out
for translation they say we test whether
gpt2 has begun to learn how to translate
from one language to another in order to
help it infer that this is the desired
task we condition the language model on
a context of example pairs of the format
English sentence equals French sentence
and then after a final prompt of English
sentence equals we sample from the model
with greedy decoding and use the first
generated sentence as the translation
incredible and what you see emerging
there is this idea of demonstrations
including in the prompt some examples of
the behavior that you want as a way of
coaxing the model to do what you would
like it to do here's a similar example
they say similar to translation the
context of the language model is seated
with example question answer pairs which
helps the model infer the short answer
style of the data set so that's for QA
and again they started to see that
demonstrations could help the model see
what the implicit task instruction was
and they also in the paper evaluate a
bunch of other things text completion
Winograd schemas and reading
comprehension and maybe others it's a
very impressive and thorough exploration
very open about the benefits and
limitations of the methods a very
impressive and creative paper
that was the beginning of the idea in
terms of research
the cultural moment certainly arrives
with the gpt3 paper Brown at all 2020
which is also impressive in its own ways
and here I'm just going to quote from
the abstract and we can linger a bit
over what it says
they start we show that scaling up
language models greatly improves task
agnostic fuchsia performance sometimes
even reaching competitiveness with prior
state-of-the-art fine-tuning approaches
we could quibble with whether or not
they actually saw competitiveness in
that sense but it is absolutely true
that they got very impressive behaviors
out of their model in this task agnostic
few shot setting
specifically we train gpt3 an
auto-regressive language model with 175
billion parameters 10x more than any
previous non-sparce language model and
test its performance in the few shot
settings there are two things I really
like about this part first 175 billion
parameters is indeed incredibly
ambitious and impressive even today to
say nothing of back in 2020 and I also
really love that they mentioned
non-sparce language model a nod to those
engram based models that I mentioned
before which were often truly massive
for all tasks gpt3 is applied without
any gradient updates or fine-tuning with
tasks and few shot demonstrations
specified purely via text interaction
with the model that's nice you might
think in retrospect that they're kind of
repeating themselves here they've
already established that these are going
to be frozen models but I think it's
necessary for them to do that because
this was such an unfamiliar idea and I
can imagine again being a reader of this
paper and assuming that they can't
really mean they're just using Frozen
models for all these tasks surely there
is some fine tuning somewhere and so
they're emphasizing that in fact the
model is entirely Frozen
gpt3 achieves strong performance on many
NLP data sets including translation
question answering and closed tasks as
well as several tasks that require
on-the-fly reasoning or domain
adaptations such as unscrambling words
using a novel word in a sentence or
performing three-digit arithmetic I love
this a real diversity of tasks and what
I think you can see them doing is really
trying to push the limits of what would
be possible in this mode
at the same time we also Identify some
data sets where gpt3's fuse shock
learning still struggles as well as some
data sets where gpt3 faces
methodological issues related to
training on large web corpora I also
love this sentence it's again very open
about what they achieved and where the
limitations are they're acknowledging
that they found some tasks that are
still hard for the model and they also
acknowledge in the paper that they had
some sort of minor slip UPS where they
intended to make sure they hadn't
trained on data that was relevant for
the test task that they were performing
and in fact they had not quite gotten
that right and so they're being very
open about that and kind of exploring
how hard it is to get that right at the
scale that they're operating at so just
like the gpt2 paper a wonderfully open
and thorough exploration of the ideas